what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again
with another demonstrator video in
preparation for the second season which
should drop
sooner or later this year i'm down to
drop a bunch of demonstrator videos as
long as you guys continue to watch them
and continue to show your love by
smashing that like button until it's
blue that's the best way to ensure
consistent demonstrator content for you
as well as commenting below to help the
youtube algorithm know to share this
video with other demonstrator fans
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demon slayer videos
and while you wait for your suggestion
to be made feel free to check out my
growing demonstrator playlist which
includes videos on all the hashira all
demon moons
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
i've been meaning to make one of these
videos for a while where i examined the
relationship between two characters
it's been in the back of my mind for a
while now so i decided to finally give
it a shot with one of my favorite
couples in demonstrator
another favorite couple is zenitsu and
nezuko so if you want to see that
too destroy that like button and let me
know in the comments
kano debuts as early as chapter 6
believe it or not during the final
selection exam we just see her gentle
smile and don't spend much time with her
but like zaitsu and genya she was
singled out foreshadowing her future
importance in the story
she was one of the almost 20
participants and one of the five to
actually survive
so it wasn't really love at first sight
here since kanel
was just in the background as tundra was
carrying out his goal in trying to help
his sister let's fast forward
now to the natagumo mountain arc
at this point she came with giu and
shinobu as her tsuguko aka as her
apprentice and eventual successor
again this was a very romantic meeting
shinobu is trying to kill nezuko because
she's a demon while tanjiro and giu are
trying to protect nezuko from the insect
pillar
as giu is keeping shinobu busy her
assistant kanel
attacks tunjuro as he's running away
with nezuko she almost
kills nezuko tanjiro's precious sister
but tundra manages to stop her kano is a
beast though and then manages to knock
tundra out with a kick to the head
as she chases down nezuko a part of her
thinks it's weird that nezuko is just
running and not attacking but another
part of her says and i quote
just kill demons like i was taught end
quote at this point she is clearly not
allowing herself to think for herself
rather just following orders luckily the
crows let kanel know that nezuko is to
be captured
rather than killed and then she can
proceed with those new instructions
so yeah not a conventional start to a
romance imagine a girl knocked you out
with a kick
and tried to kill your sister still
arguably kanel was just doing what the
majority of demonstrators would do
following orders and trying to eliminate
demons at the butterfly mansion
things really begin to change while the
kakushi are carrying tundra there
they see kano and tanjiro stares at her
as if
it's the first time he truly saw her as
she smiles surrounded by butterflies
it's explained to tunjuro that she's a
tsuguko a demon slayer who's being
trained by a hashira only the most
talented and highly skilled fighters get
selected so she's very impressive
tundra thinks that he saw her at final
selection but he didn't notice that she
stepped on him last night hilariously
enough
while the kakushi asks if they can enter
kano just smiles vacantly
not saying anything ali then intercepts
them and
leads them away but interestingly enough
tundra stares back
looking at kano clearly showing his
interest in this
weird quiet girl who could kick his butt
the butterfly girls including kana and
aoi help with the training of our three
amigos namely tanjiro inosuke and
zenitsu
tundra being more straight laced doesn't
make a big deal of this fact while
zenitsu freaks out when he finds out
saying the girls have nice chests great
butts and strong thighs
tundra does his best not to give in to
such thoughts since
as he says he thinks it's bad to train
with such impure motivations
kano was on another level and
continually beat the three demon slang
amigos
in the game of tag and in the cup
throwing game they marveled at her
abilities and how even though she joined
at the same time as them
she was so much ahead of them tunjiro
was the opposite and actually lagged
behind zanitsu and inosuke to the point
where he felt embarrassed
still after losing to kanau the
unbeatable for five days straight
zanitsu and inosuke stopped showing up
but tanjiro kept coming and working hard
and lost for another 10 days straight
tundra wondered why he couldn't beat her
and pointed out that she smelled closer
to ahashira and that her eyes were
different finally tanja realizes that
the big difference is that he doesn't
use total concentration breathing 24
hours a day while the hashira and kanao
do
we find out that kanel can use breathing
to burst huge
hard gourds and tundra is absolutely
shocked that a skinny girl like her can
do it through hard work and total
concentration breathing tangero manages
to eventually catch kano in tag
and beat her in the cup game except he
doesn't want to throw the smelly medical
tee in her face so he puts the cup on
her head which still counts as a win
you gotta love these moments they have
and even though tundra did beat her here
kanel actually had more up her sleeve as
we'll find out later it has something to
do with the fact that tundra said her
eyes are different than most people's
but the fact that these two
are both such strong fighters also makes
them a nice match in my books
now let's fast forward to when tundra
thanks kano for everything and is
heading out again
again kano smiles and remains quiet
there's an extended moment of silence
before kano finally takes out a coin and
flips it after seeing the result it's
hilarious how unintentionally cold and
formal kano's response is
she states that i quote i merely
followed my teacher's instructions so
you don't need to thank me goodbye
end quote no nice to spend time with you
no i like you not even a you're welcome
nevertheless tundra is just shocked she
spoke clearly tanjo is drawn to kano
even in these earlier parts in the story
since not a lot of people would stay so
long considering kano's behavior
kano keeps repeating goodbye while
tundra keeps talking
asking her about what she threw and why
she threw it
then kana opens up and says i quote i
toss this to the side things for which i
haven't been
told what to do just now i decided
whether i would speak to you or not
heads meant i wouldn't and tails meant i
would it came up tails so i spoke and
quote crazy to think if the end result
would have changed
if she got heads and didn't speak to
tundra but with how persistent tanjuro
is it may not have even mattered as kano
says goodbye
again for the thousandth time tundra
keeps a conversation going
asking kanel why she can't decide for
herself what to do
no response he continues and i quote
what did you want to do for yourself
end quote kano not saying goodbye this
time which is progress in and of itself
says it doesn't matter nothing matters
at all so i can't decide by myself
tundra blows her mind and heart wide
open when he says
i think everything in this world matters
he goes on to tell her that he bets the
voice in her heart is soft but
it's also important to follow
instructions he asks to borrow her coin
and surprise surprise she says yes
without flipping the coin
so tundra has already started to get
kanel out of her robotic-like existence
he then throws the coin and says that
this will decide if she listens closely
to the voice in her heart from now on
if it's heads she'll have to live by her
heart to usually calm and vacant kano is
now
wide awake and even sweating as she
awaits the result
they both see its heads and tundra is
overjoyed and tells kano that
she can do it the heart is what drives
us her heart can get
infinitely strong it's like hanel had
been frozen in time in a sense
and she just melted during this exchange
and started to really live again
by the way tanjiro grabs the hands of
the now nervous canal
another clue that they'd end up together
as tundra rushes off saying goodbye
kano is now full of energy and screaming
after him how did he know
it would come up heads was tundra really
leaving this all to fate or chance
kano wants to know if it was a valid
throw she thinks to herself that she was
watching his hand
and she doesn't think that he cheated
and this is one of my favorite parts in
demonstrator right here
tundra smiles and says it was just
chance but here's the kicker
he adds besides if it was tails i was
going to flip it over and over
until i got heads tundra was not going
to leave this to chance
he was going to keep going until he made
sure that
kanau started listening to her heart he
tells her to take care as she remains
there
holding the coin that tundra had just
held to her heart
when another girl catches her off guard
khan austria falls over
clearly flustered about her reawakened
feelings and more specifically probably
about her feelings for tanjiro and
after this scene between tanjo and kano
no one should be surprised that they end
up together
tanjiro's consistent effort and interest
in kano and the fact that kano's heart
was pretty much reawakened by him
is heavy foreshadowing for what's to
come so i don't want
anyone saying that this matchup came
from left field
since this significant and life-changing
scene was in the very first season
by the way because of the nature of this
video i won't be focusing too much on
kano's backstory
although i do go into it more in my how
strong is kanel video link in the
description long story short though she
had a very difficult upbringing
she grew up in poverty and in an abusive
home
she witnessed siblings pass away and if
she cried
she would get punished not surprisingly
she eventually broke psychologically and
was sold into slavery before
kanae and shinobu saved her although
they physically rescued her she was like
an
empty shell and kane had to give her a
coin to flip before she could even make
any decision
thus tundra straight up mends her broken
psyche here and although she will still
grow as a character from here
the wheels are clearly turning again
making tanjiro already one of the most
important figures in her life up to this
point
now we fast forward to tundra waking up
from his
coma after the fight against upper moons
gyutaro and daki who's the first person
he sees
none other than a concerned canal who
straight up drops and breaks a vase when
she sees he's up
she's no longer the empty shell she once
was she reveals that he's been
unconscious for two months
clearly she's been looking after him and
then she gives us one of the most
heartwarming
smiles with what appeared to be tears
coming from her
eyes and she tells tenjo that she's glad
he's awake
full ship ahead it's a moment that's
easy to gloss over
if you're waiting to get to the fight
but it shows
just how much kanao has come to care
about tanjiro the fact that she's the
first to see him suggest that she
in all likelihood spent the most time by
his bed now let's skip over to kano's
fight against upper moon 2
doma the whole fight is amazing but i'll
try to focus on the details that stand
out from a tundra
and kanel perspective the first thing
i'll mention and go back to is how kanel
like tanjiro the chosen one
is an amazing fighter in her own right
making them quite the power couple
doma says that kanao might just be a
little more skillful than shinobu who
he's just eaten
and that's before kannau even shows him
her full power
this is an important fight for kanau
because she is avenging both kane
and shinobu both of who rescued her from
slavery
and died at the hands of doma by this
point kano is definitely not
a vacant shell she is burning with
passion and specifically with hatred for
doma inosuke helps kano in this fight as
does shinobu who poisoned doma when he
ate her but kano is still amazing in it
she uses one of my favorite breath style
techniques ever
called the flower breathing final form
vermilion eye
which is pretty much like a shotting gun
with its own unique spin
it makes surrounding movements look dull
and slow and it causes pressure on the
eyes and that pressure stains them red
kano uses this ability and with the help
of inosuke and shinobu's poison
succeeds in defeating doma finally
carrying out her revenge
as a result of using this op technique
though she loses vision in her right
eye after the battle we find out that
kanel
couldn't cry for kanai after she died
but everyone was kind and didn't think
less of her because she couldn't show
emotion
and finally she cries harder than ever
the floodgates
open symbolizing that with her defeat of
doma
she's fully regained her ability to show
her emotions
similarly tundra completes his revenge
arc by finally beating muzon
with the help of everyone else and like
kano he loses vision in his right eye in
the process
and although it's sad that they both
lose vision in one eye it's yet another
thing
that for us hardcore romantics makes
them perfect for each other
and makes it seem like they're fated to
be together but let's not gloss over
this final battle because there are
quite a few
important moments concerning kano and
tanjuro there is a point where muzon has
taken out
almost everyone including the strongest
pillar and kano looks like the only
fighter left
he approaches her and is about to finish
her off and tundra swoops in with the
save using the legendary dance of the
fire god style and takes kanel away to
safety
at this point half of tundra's face is
mutated but he doesn't seem to care
he just apologizes to kanel for being
late and tells the kakushi to take care
of her
it's a complete 180 from the time kano
easily knocked him out with a kick and
you'd love to see it
however it's not just tundra doing the
saving kano's turn comes up
when tundra becomes an overpowered demon
kano still had some anti-demon medicine
and when she sees the state tundra is in
she realizes that this
is the reason she still has one eye left
kanel bless her heart
uses vermilion eye with her one
remaining eye in order to save tanjiro
she gets hurt in addition to hurting her
last remaining eye with her special
technique but it doesn't bother her as
she says
all she wishes for is for tanjiro to
come back to them
and you can noticeably see that her
words reach him
just as tundra saved kano kano was
willing to risk not just her vision but
her entire life
to save tanjiro as well and this effort
of kano
along with the words she speaks as well
as the medicine she gives tanjiro is the
big push which helps him return to the
world of humans as tundra recovers
kano is laying there in the distance as
well being treated for her injuries
they're both immobile laying on the
ground and they make eye contact and
both smile
and cry having just saved each other it
is such
a beautiful moment then during chapter
204 the second last chapter tundra and
kano share a great moment
after they've recovered to an extent
from their injuries they talk about how
the first user of flower breathing
planted the sakura tree in front of them
and named it victory kano wanted to tell
the tree that they succeeded and tunjiro
can't help but think
how kind this was of her they continue
to talk about how they are doing
and both delight in kaburamaru the snake
that kano inherited from iguro the snake
pillar although kano definitely lost
some vision
in her remaining eye by using vermilion
eye to save tanjiro
she does explain that she still has some
vision left
although they part ways and tanjo is
having dinner with zenitsu nezuko and
inosuke at the end of this chapter
the next chapter pretty much reveals who
got together with whom
chapter 205 is a huge time skip where we
first meet the descendants of kano and
tanjiro namely kanata kamado
who looks very similar to kano and
sumihiko kamado who looks very similar
to
tanjiro i have no doubt the name kanata
itself is a reference to kano's name
just as aoba is a reference to aoi
suggesting that aoi got together with
inosuke and at this point some fans
suggested that the ships still weren't
official because descendants of these
characters
might have gone together rather than the
main characters themselves
immediately i was like no way to this
possibility
and the mangaka clearly had my back and
was kind enough to create an extended
ending where it was confirmed that
tundra
and kanel did get together and were
kanata and sumihiko's great great
grandparents
in this extended ending we also saw
flashbacks of tundra and kanel getting
closer
being nice to some crows together and
being wrapped around together by their
pet snake kaburamaru who was probably a
good wingman for tanjiro
and in the final panel tanjiro is
holding nezuko's hand with his left hand
and kano's hand with his right which is
perfect i love to see them together in
the final panel of the series
by the way if you are confused and
haven't seen this extended new ending i
will leave a link to the video i made
about it in the description of this
video
so there we have it the relationship
between tanjiro and kanel
fully explained although it didn't seem
super promising at the start when kanel
knocked him out and tried to kill his
sister they got over that hurdle
with a little help from tundra's amnesia
since he hilariously enough didn't even
remember she did that
after tundra flipped that coin at the
butterfly estate there was arguably no
going back and their ship kept getting
more and more perfect from there
they were both willing to risk their
lives for one another and were both
saved by one another on multiple
occasions and in multiple ways
i truly love this couple and after her
terrible upbringing i'm so glad
kanel got with someone she deserves
someone as
kind as tanjiro it truly warms my heart
every time i think of this
perfect ship but let me know your
thoughts on this couple
and if it's your favorite in
demonstrator or if you prefer another
one in the series
if you did enjoy this video show
demonstrator some love by smashing that
like button until it's blue
especially if you want to see similar
videos for zenitsu and nezuko
inosuke and aoi and so on if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications
or you will miss future demons player
videos and while you wait for your
suggestion to be made
feel free to check out my growing
demonstrator playlist which includes
videos on all the hashira
all demon moons and much more link to
that is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who help make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one to your
patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata pate heffa al-jatal dr
corbin the toaster chi
emperor taku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d quilly and our pro hero
tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel crews
anatoly kazatsky very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia ted note 10 fat boy games corey
mcgowan
metal mama deadly saint and soul rise
slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
animeoutpro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button
next to the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you